but how exciting is it to you know play
in a brand new
stadium like a legion i'm sure you know
you've had moments like this before
maybe if you could just kind of describe
that to kind of break in a new place
like this
yeah man i mean it feels you feel very
lucky to be called
they say hey for opening stadium would
you do you kid me i'd love to
and then there's the thing where you go
in and hopefully
after tonight or that sound check we'll
do we'll take some notes
uh for the building as well for future
concerts and then tomorrow night we're
going to take a lot of notes
to pass on them for future concerts
because i want people to come play this
stadium because standing down there
there's not a bad seat in the house
very rare because football stadiums are
built for
football right not concerts this thing
was built with concerts in mind you can
tell
so we were just talking about vegas how
you've you know played all these
different places maybe if you could talk
about you know what vegas has really
meant to you
through the span of your career yeah
well the the the greatest thing about
vegas and everybody talks about the
lights and
all that stuff the greatest thing about
vegas are the people they just are
because it's these people that are at
the root of everything so let's go all
the way back to the desert inn let's go
all the way back to thomas mack
those people are just
just common sense people and that's what
makes you feel at home when you when you
come in and people
people seem to be putting on an act
you're like i don't feel at home here
vegas is the home of supposedly smoke
and mirrors
but the people that run all the sweetest
people on the planet so it's it's like
coming home here it's good
and being a part of you know the
comeback of vegas and really the
comeback of the country you know for
any artists for just kind of anybody how
how great does that feel to kind of
really be part of that
propelling back into normalcy well we
feel lucky but we also feel
you got you have to be responsible about
it right so as much as we all want to go
out and be
those musicians that had no
responsibility before
now responsibility comes into being a
musician and so for the rest of this
year
we're all mass mandated in our entire
tour since we're going from city to city
and we just want to make sure that if
the covet is truly
on the back side of us that it stays
there and we have to do our part so feel
very lucky to be part of this but at the
same time the message is
bring respect for each other and look
out for other people that's what we do
last question what would it feel like
you know or what is your message rather
to you know maybe those coming out to
your show tomorrow night
but having a good time what they can
expect how exciting this is for them
well the message first of all is if you
see somebody in a mask don't look odd at
them
and if you're wearing a mask and
somebody isn't don't look odd at them
we're all kind of getting out of this
thing at our own speed right so let's
come be a family
let's sing that's the main thing because
the more you sing the less i
have to do anything right i love sitting
there just
watch it it's so good so uh it's fun
just come out and just have fun and
i'll tell you the exact same thing i
tell the band at the handshake before
the thing
for the show for the next two three
hours
there is nothing you can do about
anything outside these walls
come here turn it off and turn it on no
we'll have fun